ce que non mais ce que voulait faire et
vous une entrée peu non non si merci
d'être avec nous et bien sûr vous
l'attendez vous l'attendez depuis le
début de la saison
vous attendez je fais je peux venir
c'est là on est complet où les attendait
bien sûr depuis le début de la saison et
c'est les premières les premières quatre
tiers de la saison avec le génie jean
luc lemoine
on respecte pas ce que c'est les
chrétiens balesi position visiter
l'appartement
est-ce que ça c'est qu'on la location
les quatre tiers jean-luc il regarde
tout ce qui se passe pendant les pubs de
l'émission pendant les transitions
pendant les magnétos parce qu'ils se
parlent beaucoup les chroniqueurs
pendant les lives aussi et il a un oeil
qui voit ce qu'on ne voit pas et
malheureusement ça fait toujours mal ou
chroniqueurs ou à moi mais j'aime bien
je le prends bien et il y aura un peu de
pour tout le monde aujourd'hui toujours
je distribue à ouimet moment un marchand
de bonheur
videmment à la question tout de suite
allez on y va
bonjour je m'appelle fanni dans ma
chambre j'ai accroché de la nouvelle
photo de rentrer de tpm p elle est très
jolie mais s'il vous plaît
pouvez vous me dire qui sont ces gens
que je ne connais pas
c'est très compliqué de répondre à votre
question chère famille car c'est vrai
que cette année cyril nous a gâtés
d'habitude sur la photo on a des gens
qu'on connaît et qu'on ne reverra jamais
cette année on a eu le droit des gens
qu'on ne reverra sans doute pas mais dès
que dès le départ on ne connaissait pas
regardez c'est des gens qui rend compte
au supermarché
ces photos c'est l'arche de noé c'est un
projet cc c'est pas une promesse vous
remarquerez au passage contre cyril et
valérie et une silhouette en cas retour
de matthieu delormeau et surtout un
habile montage fait par un enfant de 12
ans pour inclure nabila en haut à droite
ah ben oui c'est très bien fait mais pas
remarqué que c'est la villa vous croyez
c'était qui je sais pas alors à famille
on n'en peut mais mais oui mais oui
c'est vrai est ce que vous connaissez
les noms de toutes les personnes
alors je vais pas les données parce que
bon on n'a pas le temps mais pas
forcément veille à géraldine maillet il
ya des gens donc le 3 septembre c'est la
rentrée de l'émission est ce que vous
savez comment ça s'est passé
ça a commencé par une parodie de mission
impossible ah oui ou si le découvre et
son équipe
ça c'est ce que vous avez vu à l'antenne
les chroniqueurs eux ils attendaient sur
scène avec angie girac et tout le monde
a beaucoup aimé la présentation
d'isabelle isabelle morini bosc
cette journaliste dispose des meilleures
informations sur tous ses amis d'enfance
napoléon du café ou encore vercingétorix
le canard
d'ailleurs pas nouveau et c'est de
remplacer
[Musique]
ça va ok quand même ça démarre mal ça va
nous manquer mais moi c'est ça sème pas
mais vous allez voir la vie mais c'est
fini les clash entre kyriat gat miles
soit plus bas oui mais que va devenir
l'émission heureusement cyril pense à
tous donc cette année vous aurez droit à
une autre tension entre deux
chroniqueuses isabelle morini bosc et
daniel moreau c'est une autre ambiance
oui je vous dis tout de suite c'est pas
le même délire non d'après vous c'est
quoi leur sujet de discorde les mecs il
sera la plus section plateau que non
quant au respect de la tête c'est sur
des vrais sujets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
quand cette fois du match
c'est chaud c'est un show à la télé
pouvait pas se blairer elles sont pas
alimentaire compatibles et 2 ça va
clasher sévère à ma cantine vous l'aimez
bien daniel ou pas fait dit la vérité à
jabel isabelle bizarre quand même
je vais beaucoup de vaudois alors vous
le savez cette forêt était un peu
mouvementée qu'un la première semaine il
l'a dit cyril avait tout changé et la
deuxième semaine il a ressorti du
placard son vieux conducteur de l'année
dernière au passage sur des étagères est
tombé sur maxime gagné il l'a ressorti
aussi un coup dessus des missions est
devenue ce qu'elle est et pour le plus
grand bonheur des fans 12 et des
chroniqueurs
non mais
[Musique]
surtout c'est pas que maxime c'est que
jean michel ribes du style parce que
leur oui c'était sûr mais il a voulu lui
faire plaisir
toujours matzinger toujours les journées
comme ça ouais je sais de feu ont dû
s'arrêter à dieu c'est le problème quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il ya moyen de prétendants
ici oui c'est un petit peu le bachelor
voilà vous savez vous serez gentil vous
l'appelez monsieur delormeau ça marchera
comme les nouveautés il ya des choses
que les gens ne savent pas et c'est
important de le signaler car série
laisse très strictes là dessus pas de
porte à badens plateau ça que dt chasse
est interdite à johnny car depuis le
départ de camille combal ah oui il veut
pas que les chroniqueurs pyrite
géolocaliser kidnappé par tf1 donc tout
le monde a son téléphone aux vestiaires
peu de téléphone sauf le rebelle aux
cheveux d'or
haha
mercer
ea mateur palmarès est regardant mission
c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
mardi par et pour la question de la
couleur dit géraldine moi je vous ai
fait formidable elle apparaît prenait la
question alain keler ton émission vaut
mieux ne pas avoir des missions que
d'avoir une émission déprogrammé
[Rires]
vu qu'il a fait la première ce soir ce
qui est un scoop que vous avez marre
j'ai rien vous savez il ya des gens qui
font des choses en début d'année qui les
font pas en novembre à l'eau la dernière
ce soit pour moi je défends géraldine a
bien sûr vous avez raison bah oui mais
il faut dire que c'est à des mathieux
faut pas le chercher il est prescrite et
avec tout le monde devrait il a un sens
de la répartie avez le sens de la
répartie de mathieu maman d'ilan et
prend son temps avant de répliquer mais
quand ça sort ça va réfléchir aussi
longtemps qu'il y avait osé lui parler
de son décolleté un peu excessif
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça laisse ça c'est pas pour toi
arrête ça laisse ça ouais un défilé tout
évidemment tout ceci est faux perso de
pré-embauche maxime guinée maxime veut
pas savoir et non c'est faux c'est la
vie privée non mais c'est sa vie privée
ou ne veut pas le savoir mais c'est vrai
c'était une blague de ces matches tout
cas c'est une magnifique transition pour
le top 16 ans
oui car l'hymne est de retour cette
compilation des petits moments qui ne
peuvent arriver que dans tpm mais demain
on aura marois l'aude
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
cammalleri
[Musique]
ces quelques
j'adore
lancée
je t'adore
[Musique]
ok
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses premières leçons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous a plu
ah oui j'adore ça fait du bien donc là
bas y est dans les nouveaux chroniqueurs
cyril a recruté en profite qu'on n'avait
pas jusque là le marieur le mec qui te
met en couple en moins de 30 minutes
c'est qui si le mec accueil tu parles tu
as l'impression qu'ils te faire de vie
et que trouver une loupe pour lui c'est
comme poser du lino et ce profit qu'on
n'avait pas c'est quentin mosimann vrai
y'a pas que derrière les platines qu'il
est bon celui-là je sais pas si c'est un
bluffeur mais avec maxime gainey m'a
vendu du rêve
le vélo à tulle à genève
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoutant problème
j'ai un créneau roger un créneau samedi
ça entre 13h et 14h et josiane là qui
rendent la veille ça rit ça il est
basique l'animal écoute je trouvais ça
alors et masquer ce marché de rencontre
j'ai perdu mon mot de passe c'est pas un
site de rencontres pigeon points comme
kinder surprise a alors vous étiez pas
déjà sûr inquiets mais j'ai sur ces
affaires là il est revenu il y avait le
pêcheur a été chassé je pense que maxime
dillies façon va pas finir là mais seuls
car même si quand on les trouve pas
chaussure à son pied et déjà quelqu'un
qui a pris des renseignements non une
nouvelle recrue le ragoût qui daniel
moreau non je voudrais pas m'avancer
mais je pense que ça va coûter beaucoup
plus que les autres années en coulisse
non thermiques et les gouttes
a toujours brouillé les pistes
[Musique]
c'était
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
meilleure définition missile envoyé
signe un ballet des signes ce qui aa
vous seriez intéressés n'ont même pas
d'accord vous avez les appels de phare
et assez voyons je pense pas qu'on va
les bras bon bah très moyenne un peu
plus jeune mais quand même ça ça va me
manquer j'aime tous deux évoqué même
plus et on commence par cyril là il est
venu en guest de jogging oui on a essayé
de changer il n'a pas voulu il a fait
son modèle mais c'est monsieur delormeau
oui parce que je veux c'est les maths a
fait cette année comme tu veux le même
mais comme lewis et moi vous vendez du
tout en tout cas plus pas toujours si tu
crois au fait des années que cette année
j'ai bien un petit peu sport animateurs
les grandes audiences
il vous manque beaucoup de trucs alors
dont le il y en a un peu plus on
commence par cyril qui aime bien faire
des petits commentaires pendant qu'on
diffuse des magnétos and on and on passa
à c'est kelly aussi aime bien non le
problème c'est qu'à lemoine sens du
timing
un refus d'admettre ischios et n'a pas
une fonction de protection rapprochée en
algérie permis de port d'armes
faites vous appeler
et pourquoi je n'ai pas fait soleil plus
en fait je devrais faire lui si
j'entends votre voix je vais peut-être
me mettre à chialer comme un gosse je
lui fais pas la pression il a été très
bon au pilote afin que manger d'arabe
[Musique]
baal et sochaux est bonne parce que
quand il est au chômage
[Musique]
mercredi 12 septembre le pire stagiaires
ouverte à sans connexion internet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui l'ait
nos métiers benjamin castadi quitte à
passer des vacances sans rigoler à nous
montrer son corps
[Musique]
il adore flory la productrice
d'émissions j'adore son vous la montrera
demain en raison des pratiques et
apparemment elle a le béguin
non il allie la réunion me la kiffer
[Musique]
citation trop c'est fini
noda son médecin qu'il y compris pour
ceux qui veulent saboter
alors
[Musique]
c'est moi qui la montre avec bien sûr le
plus long séjour büchel toujours une
belle constance il est toujours présent
là dedans oui j'en ai mathieu débrouille
pas mal
dans un autre cas la libération de m oui
c'est vrai merci et vous ça va vous
sinon vous avez rigolé pendant 10 à
beaucoup il sait tout ce que vous avez
fait ça fait du bien bonjour lui que je
voudrais te remercier ben merci voudrait
qu'on applaudisse très
et on refait la fenêtre
[Applaudissements]